[Musik]
ein schiff der organizer in der
grafikabteilung einer bank allein
erziehende mutter mit begeisterung und
im sehr gespannt auf das gespräch dass
jetzt gleich und in arbeit hier und
frankfurt in der cockpit finance
beratung
wir beraten unternehmen bei der anlegung
von fremdkapital selber privat habe ich
drei kinder und freue mich heute hier
auf die gelegenheit diskutieren zu
können
der hat kaum eine frau die seit wirklich
aus eigenen situation schafft auch mit
wenig zu besuchen
genau da
nehmen das kann ich mir wunderbar früher
stellen grundsätzlich diskutiere ich
ganz gerne und je weiter man hier im
alltag unterwegs ist und auch kollegen
und freunden diskutiert ist halt doch
irgendwo ausgetretene pfade filter blase
in der man sich bewegt und man muss ja
für eine gute diskussion wenn man die
jetzt schon sehr weit radikalisieren und
überhaupt noch infusionen zu führen zu
können und es hier einfach mal auch
andere sichtweisen kennenzulernen
ich glaube das würde mich selbst auch
bereichern allein dass mein
gesprächspartner mann ist ist schon mal
ein ganz starker andere sichtweise weil
er ganz andere situation erleben wird
als ich und darüber sprechen diskutieren
erzählen gegenseitig und das möchte ich
eigentlich neues lernen
klar kann ich versuchen zu überzeugen
aber ich bin nicht zwingend
ein thema das mich sehr immer wieder
umtreibt jetzt witzigerweise im alter
sogar mehr ist das thema frau und mann
und die chancengleichheit die ich mit
zunehmendem alter abnimmt beurteilen
am meisten freut mich auch ein stück
weit wie meine vorredner schon sagt ja
auf mann frau war das glaube ich auch
ein gerade sehr polarisiert das thema
ist in den in den medien auch eine
gesellschaft und auch ein stück weit was
hier gerade im zuge der klimadebatte mit
der besteuerung von co2 und flugzeugen
ist das ist die zwei themen die mich am
meisten gerade bewegen kann wir sind
glaube ich die abgebracht werden
da muss ich jetzt fest dass du glaubst
dass es eine benachteiligung
unser schlechtes ist oder verpasste
chance und das geschlecht ist bleibt ist
einfach in den köpfen veränderten halten
in anspruch
ja nicht wirklich wir wie übersteht dann
dann ist es ein normaler debattenkultur
auch in der frucht reiche debattenkultur
problem ist nur wenn wir über soziale
medien oder über medien generell
sicherheit alle möglichen punkten kopf
schmeißt das ist ein bisschen schwierig
eine richtige ordentliche diskussion ist
für mich gekennzeichnet von
gegenseitigem respekt ausreden lassen
sie speisen stehen lassen
aber kennen lernen oder durch erkenntnis
gewinnen die eigene sichtweise
modifizieren anpassen komplett ändern
das alles denken
[Musik]
großes vergnügen es gab keine pause
keine lücke wir mehr an lassen uns durch
die verschiedenen themen die auch durch
die fragen an gerissen waren
und es hängt alles irgendwie immer
zusammen
und wenn man irgendwann anfängt faden
rauszuziehen dann zieht er sich über
alle möglichen themen hat spaß gemacht
braucht ja sehr angeregt und immer
wieder was man feststellen muss ist mir
dann doch obwohl sechs triebel fragen
gestellt worden sind schwarz weiß ja
nein ist man im kern dann doch zusammen
nur außen wo auseinander ist aber auch
das gehalt weiter man
[Musik]
eine diskussion voran geschritten ist es
hängt alles mit allem zusammen
also man kann vom landfrau thema
wirklich auf die mieten kommen und den
eingriff des staates
und ob aus deutschland abgehängt ist
oder nicht und ob jetzt dann doch das
flugbenzin besteuert werden soll es sind
alles zusammen
[Musik]